[Music]
welcome to quad riga as we speak some of
the world's most powerful leaders are
assembling in canada for the annual
summit of the g7 countries even before
the meeting began there were predictions
of acrimony on the agenda is US
president Trump's decision to impose
punitive tariffs on steel and aluminium
imports coming from the EU Mexico and
Canada some observers are predicting a
six against one confrontation with
Donald Trump the odd man out but
divisions in Europe make a united front
ever more difficult to achieve has
Trump's America first transactional ISM
become the nationalist template for
other leaders including within the EU
Trump goes it alone Europe at a loss
that's our topic on quadriga today and
here are our guests it's a pleasure to
welcome Laura fun Daniel she's a senior
fellow at the Berlin based think tank
swp her research focuses on US economic
policy and trade and she says the EU is
currently doing a remarkable job at
protecting its interests in very
challenging times and I'm glad to
welcome Ralph point on the show he is
spokesperson of the German section of
Republicans overseas and he says there
has been a trade imbalance for years
between the u.s. and the EU the
complaints of the Europeans about
punitive tariffs are therefore not
justified and finally we're glad to have
darrell lindsay with us he's managing
editor of Spiegel international he says
Europe is for the most part united
against Trump on tariffs for now but
what if this turns into a full-fledged
trade war and let me start out by asking
you Laura and Daniel's are we likely to
see the g7 devolve into a g6 plus-one as
Frances finance minister recently said
and if so what implications does that
have for Europe and for the world as a
whole well first of all it's good that
all of those countries and their leaders
they're coming together and trying to
have a dialogue it's often forgotten
that there are plenty of topics to talk
about that are really important besides
and the economic parts and I think
there's stay a pretty good chance also
for other countries even if the u.s. is
following a different path on trade and
is leading a more protectionist policy
approach right now there's still a
chance that all of those other countries
that are united in the g7 and the g20
and also all of the member states of the
WTO will be able to carry on and just
stick to the global liberal
international order do you really think
they're going to get to any other topics
at this summit besides trade I surely
hope they will because they're really
big crisis like the one in Syria and
eastern Ukraine other topics that are
really relevant that we should be
talking about topics like equal rights
for women and men and so on if you have
a look at the agenda for the g7 also
climate change these are really the
topics that we should be talking about
rather than always getting into those
fights right the u.s. gov find is giving
as it's official justification for
imposing these punitive tariffs not
unfair trading practices actually but
national security by perceiving under
what is a fairly obscure national law
rather than under standard WTO
procedures isn't the u.s. ultimately
thumbing its nose at its allies and
perhaps at that rule-based international
order in general sure a bit I mean I'm
certainly Trump need to react fastly so
he needed a reason in order to do to act
like this I believe actually the reason
is a bit different we have and we don't
have an equivalent and the tariffs and
that has to be solved for many many
years we reclaimed this you know the
u.s. claimed this many years like other
administration Obama but also Clinton
George Bush jr. for instance they
claimed this many many times and nothing
has happened and the WTO acts quite
slowly and takes years and years I mean
it's just talking about bananas with
Guatemala took many years for a very
minor thing so I believe we need some
action now we have a open discussion as
we sit here for instance and
think that's very healthy and we need
and President Trump
always taken 1/2 percent of overall
trade ok so he could have like we could
have talked about other goods like like
like cars automotive and like that he
didn't so he started up with something
very much but the minor thing I believe
and now we the Europeans have to be
unified and they have to act have to
speak with one voice and I think these
talks will proceed and I think we will
get to a very positive end okay I want
to come back to a couple of those points
that you made in just a moment but first
looking at the big picture
Darrell Lindsey it was shortly after the
last g7 summit that took place in Italy
that Donald Trump announced that he was
leaving thee that the US would be
leaving the Paris climate agreement
many Europeans see that together with
these tariffs together with the u.s.
retreat from the Iran treaty that it had
signed up to as the u.s. essentially
turning its back on the entire
international order that was established
after the Second World War
do you see a risk of that and if so what
do you see as the implications I see
taken together there's a there's a very
real risk of that happening you know the
question that a lot of people are asking
now is it America for stores in America
only all of these moves represent and
move away from the multilateral system
that the United States actually built in
the post-war era out of its own
interests and it does definitely feel
like there's a risk of moving away from
that I mean the real danger is if this
grows into a tit for tat if your
response in July as it plans to do
currently and then if it goes beyond
that if Trump follows through with the
punitive tariffs on automobiles which is
currently being explored by the
government then things get very serious
because then you'll see a slow divide a
wedge going through Europe because
obviously the Germans have a very
different perspective because
automobiles are the sort of the engine
of the economy whereas France has
different take they'd like to be very
firm with Trump but France doesn't even
really sell out of mobiles in the United
States they've been absent from the
market for decades whether in fact their
spreads on to the automobile sector is
very much a question of the potential
for an escalating trade board that Utah
about in your opening statement let's
first take a look at the reaction to the
US announcement that the steel and
aluminum tariffs would now be applied to
some of the u.s. closest trading
partners and friends President Trump
seems to get along with Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau almost as well
as he does with French president
Emmanuel macron but neither Trudeau
Norma Crowe managed to talk the
president out of imposing the tariffs
[Applause]
Donald Trump has launched an assault on
international trade and those affected
are pretty upset the fact that the
president has moved forward with these
tariffs is not just gonna hurt Canadian
jobs it's gonna hurt us jobs as well I
believe it's important for the EU to
make a rapid and appropriate response
within the framework of the WTO we
believe these tariffs are not consistent
with WTO regulations this is a bad day
for the world Twitter Trump's tariffs is
this how America treats its friends
so as we all know Donald Trump is a
bargainer a deal maker and in that
context Laura Daniels are the Europeans
perhaps taking these terrorists too
seriously is this actually just Trump's
opening bid in a poker game it might be
but I would say that especially the
European Commission that's responsible
for trade policy in the EU is taking a
very rational and proportionate approach
right now and it's it's obvious and they
have declared this early on that they
need to be some counter measures
but their proportionate and now of
course everyone is waiting on what will
be the next step on the US side but we
also have to consider that there's
significant amount of a position to
further tariffs on cars Otto's auto
parts and so on within the US and it
would also be much more hurtful if Trump
actually took that action I want to talk
about that in just a moment but just to
drill a little bit deeper on what we
heard from wealth for and a moment ago
it's an argument that has been made by
the Trump administration that there are
great disparities if you look at overall
EU customs duties on American imports
compared to overall American duties on
imports from the EU now I did check the
numbers last night the official WTO
numbers it says that on average the
difference is about 1.7 percent not all
that large it would seem what's your
assessment on that you are a trade
expert well it's a typical rhetorical
trick I would say on the side of Donald
Trump and also his advises to just take
one piece out of the whole picture and
then blow it up so obviously I mean
their rules which is especially the
automobile piece as I understand it
there there is a real disparity and not
even all kinds of automobiles because if
you take pickups there's a large much
higher tariffs on pickups in the u.s.
imported from the EU than on anything
else and anywhere else in the world so
it always depends on what parts of the
whole picture you look at and also I
mean it generally it makes very little
sense to look at the trade balances and
that this has often been said and
for debate on tariffs it makes no sense
to just look at trades and goods and not
consider the significant trade surplus
and services that the US has visa via
the European Union what's your response
to that well Frank because I know that
in your day job besides working with
Republicans overseas you are involved in
the financial sector that means you are
involved in cross-border financial flows
are you not concerned that the risks of
this action could be a lot greater than
the potential gains if we're talking
about only an overall difference of 1.7%
is it really risk worth or worth risking
a trade war first of all no it's not I
mean it's wait I don't see you trade
well first of all I'm second of all I
just want to add something to the figure
1.7 it depends if you really weigh the
the the trade could be I have figures up
to two and a half percent but let's put
it in between one at 1.7 and two percent
talking about 6% in one direction and 4%
in the other is still about the third
difference which is quite a lot I'm
referring to the volume of trade first
of all and I think there are some
disparities referring to duties to
actual tariffs as they stand on a broad
range of products in the and it was at
one point negotiated absolutely correct
but at some point trade developed
differently some goods are like you like
not exported anymore some some even more
it can get exported even more so there's
an imbalance and this end balance I
believe needs to be fixed so I think it
was a very mild shot from the Trump
administration to go on those tariffs
and and I think and at at I think we
should now go into talks that was just
like as you mention it a bit in a poker
game I believe in the end we should go
on maybe go back to TTIP and go back to
the transatlantic trade agreement that
in fact the u.s. yes also walked away
from
solutely but maybe that's a new
opportunity for the new talks maybe we
should take out the investment part
because that was like the Europeans are
very critical on that part and we should
to only talk about trade but Deb
be a good start for a new negotiation we
just heard Ralph run saying he doesn't
think this could escalate into a
full-fledged trade war you did mention
that possibility in your opening
statement we have seen both the EU
Canada and Mexico now announcing what
are called counter balancing measures
that means additional targeted
terrorists within the WTO system but
that definitely would take this to
another level it's still largely
political symbolism these products that
have been chosen by Cecilia malmström
are directed at trade commissioner for
the EU or that you from Sweden and she's
selected products that are symbolic
because they come from areas where Trump
was elected and so the idea it's not i
express my fears earlier I do see a
wedge being drawn between Europe and I
think if it if it gets more serious a
trade war could see a division between
France in Germany but it's not in
Europe's interest to have a trade war
with the United States it's our closest
trading partner here our very closest
trading partner and we need to come to
some sort of compromise and I think if
you talk to any sensible German
politician they also know that something
has to be done with the tariffs on the
imports and exports here and so we need
to find we need to find a middle ground
on this and I'm optimistic good that
will happen I just fear that with all of
these other unilateral factors than the
sort of you know bully schoolyard bully
on the playground factor that Trump
represents that it's gonna create a lot
of tensions in tensions or is macron
said you're not going to negotiate when
the gun is at your head real friend
Donald Trump tweeted some months ago as
the tariffs were first announced that
trade wars are easy to win do you really
think that the u.s. can emerge
economically unscathed from a further
escalation of this and particularly
won't there at the very least be
political fallout if in fact Europeans
stopped buying for example soya beans
from farmers in the Midwest well
certainly not nobody is interested in a
trade war but still the US has in the
short run more to gain than to lose
because the Europeans are exporting more
into the US than vice-versa so in the
beginning
a us-based manufacturers use steel and
aluminium that are imported yes that
means us may see less xx or more
expensive one 1/2 percent of overall
trade so in the beginning I believe is
more symbolic I believe in the long run
it will also hurt the US economy but
right at the beginning because Europe is
just more dependent on the North
American market which is the largest
market in the world the interest is more
on european side than in US side and i
think trump is playing that card but
he's not gonna pull it at one point
laura Daniel was way in on this if you
would please and I asked earlier about
the prospects for the rules-based order
one u.s. commentator said when the
tariffs were first announced that this
would later be regarded as the day the
WTO died the World Trade Organization is
there something to that argument well
this another problem that we tend to
forget and that is US policy toward the
WTO and the court system so the dispute
settlement system of the WTO and the
u.s. is currently blocking nominations
of judges and that is a major problem
because in any kind of dispute
settlement process that we might end up
in between the US and the EU and also
Canada Mexico and all of the other
countries you don't have a functioning
dispute settlement system so that is the
bigger problem I would say rather than
talking about tariffs on steel or
t-shirts and berm and so on we should
probably focus our attention to that
problem and there the US is sort of
leaning back and saying yeah we need
reforms but then there are no proposals
for what kind of reforms they're looking
for and that's a problem so we need to
get back to the negotiation table either
at the g7 g20 level or in the WTO
membership and discuss those problems
and it's true that those problems date
back further than the Trump presidency
that's a valid argument
Darryl Lindsay is there a potential
argument to be made that this could even
strengthen the WTO in the sense that
China at least is suddenly saying very
good things about the WTO and
interestingly enough Cecilia malmström
the Trade Commissioner you
mentioned she has now filed a complaint
not only against the US actions but
against China in the WTO for its
practices on international intellectual
property so are we seeing perhaps at
least some parties reawakening to a
sense of how important the WTO actually
is I think again I think that's also
another symbolic move because while the
EU has also lodged a complaint against
the United States at the WTO and China
at the same time so it sort of shows the
United States that by going after China
it shows that we take the core issue
with steel and and and other things
which is actually China very seriously
and so we're going to have a two prong
approach we're going to challenge you
but we are also going to challenge China
so I and I think there is also a
willingness within the EU to reform the
WTO we just have to get down at the
table and I say we I'm American but um
you know they just need to get back down
at the table and have a serious
conversation want to add we have to keep
a close look on the interests of each
country certainly we are claiming free
trade and in in in in fields where we
are very competitive and in fields where
we're not very compared if you're not
claiming free trade you know of course
the Chinese wants to export this deal
and they aluminum of course and the
Germans want to export their cars but
vice versa the Europeans you know have
very high high high high high tariffs on
agricultural goods for instance and so
on so so so the interest that WTO is
always to strengthen and for their own
competitive industries I mean that
that's typical
let me ask us to take a look at the
implications of all of this for Europe
as a whole because some people say this
is a watershed moment not only for the
transatlantic relationship and for the
WTO but also for Europe nationalism and
populism are in the rise here as well
making it harder than ever for the EU to
unite on a strong course of action in
response to America's terrace Italy's
new Prime Minister's juice epic content
he leads a coalition government that
includes in
establishment party and a right-wing
party Carter says he's opposed to EU
austerity measures to reduce the
country's death in Spain Prime Minister
Mariano Rajoy was tossed out of office
last week after a vote of no-confidence
Roy's conservative People's Party has
been plagued by corruption scandals for
years in Slovenia the center-right
anti-immigration Slovenian Democratic
Party won the most seats in recent
parliamentary elections the SDP focused
its campaign on refugee policy is the
European Union losing its grip Dara
Lindsay let me pass that question right
on to you coupled with coming back to
what you said earlier you see a
potential for divisions particularly
even within between France and Germany
if this trade war or trade conflict does
heat up so perhaps you can say something
about that as well
I see two scenarios one is Trump's
overall actions are playing into the
hands of the populace in Europe it could
serve to energize them which would
further divide the European Union and
and you know protectionism which is what
Donald Trump is pursuing right now is
something that would also be pursued by
the populist in in different countries
so that kind of feeds into that but at
the same time you also see people coming
together so the question is going to be
you know if France and Germany are
playing basically one role right now in
ratcheting up the pressure on the United
States but which of these will prevail
in the end in that it's too soon to tell
Laura Daniels Donald Trump as we said
sees himself as a deal maker in the past
couple of weeks that is sometimes
sounded as if Germany's economics
minister sees himself the same way
Minister altmeyer has said a couple of
things that we might think could serve
as a basis later on for pushing the EU
to make a deal and perhaps undermine its
own commitment to a rule-based order yes
but as far as I know anything done by
the German government as well as the
French government in this
attempt to negotiate with Trump and his
administration was coordinated and also
coordinated with the European Commission
so I mean do you think it will stay that
way going forward
I truly hope so I think what needs to be
done is the strong economy like Germany
powerful Chancellor like mackerel needs
to have a she needs to understand the
needs of everyone involved and there
won't be a common European position
unless we as Germans also listen to the
needs of the southern countries also the
central Eastern European countries and
that's the only way I mean to be unified
also has costs and you know you have to
to do the internally you bargain first I
think that's what's happening right now
we see this happening of Friant is that
internally you bargain get even harder
to make given the role of the new US
ambassador here he said this week that
he sees his role within his new post as
empowering right-wing movements that is
a very unusual thing for an ambassador
to say wouldn't that amount to inciting
the divisions we just saw in that report
absolutely and I think I'm he crossed a
red line for diplomats I think that
that's not appropriate behavior I you
have to understand what foreign policy
should accomplish with it shouldn't
accomplish I mean you should accomplish
to influence other we should stay in
touch with other countries and we should
also negotiate with other countries on
foreign policy we should never never
influence domestic politics I mean
that's that's a no-go we always you know
we know this in the u.s. that the Cubans
who live now in Florida trying to put
pressure on the US administration always
do to influence the domestic politics of
Cuba it never worked out really you
should never never try this and I think
I'm a basket or grand fellow is like um
should she should learn his lesson he
never should have given the interview to
Breitbart which is viewed by many in
Europe is a propaganda channel it's like
the American version of our tea let me
ask all of you this because we are
slowly coming to the end of our time we
have seen the Chancellor and
amiracle this week giving several
interviews in which she continued to
take a somewhat ambivalent position in
regard to the proposals for European
reform that have been put out by French
president macaw and for that reason she
is being criticized by some here in
Germany and in Europe as essentially
weakening the EU at a moment when it
badly needs decisive leadership so let
me ask all of you briefly to answer the
question whether Trump ISM amounts to a
test of Europe's maturity and whether
Europe can pass that test Laura yeah I
think America really needs to think of
the long-term consequences of this
reluctance to have more European
integration that's a position that's
comfortable it gives you more leverage
to be ambivalent but now it's the moment
where you actually need to take a
decision and actually the coalition
agreement between the city you and the
SPD was pretty clear on where we want to
go where this government is going to go
in the European integration direction so
they should follow through on what they
already decided and put down in words
jerilyn to knuckle needs to do far more
she needs to be courageous or we're
going to be headed into a deep crisis in
the EU yeah absolutely
she's also my Chancellor I remember also
sufficient Democrats I think she should
um try to get the pieces together to
talk with one voice but certainly not on
Germany's bill I mean mark Rahl is
always trying that overall cost should
be split up proportionally like like
overall Europe and that means really
Germany's got to pay the biggest bill
I'm Marco should watch out that we are
politically united but economically
everybody should as it has to work on at
home focus
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us here today and thanks to
all of you for tuning in see you soon
[Music]